are some numbers more interesting than
than other numbers
and
i think they are so like an
interestingness rating yeah i think
there are um in in the following sense
there's actually a paper about this
so the numbers that are the most
interesting
are the small numbers now this might be
counterintuitive because obviously there
are large numbers that are interesting
like google graham's number googleplex
obviously don't talk about the videos
that i've made
so there are big interesting numbers but
there's actually
um a theorem
sort of a theory it's a joke paper by a
guy called richard guy who's pretty well
known mathematician and he's tried to
formulate the the strong law of small
numbers
and what he says is this is that small
numbers are too interesting as in they
they're sort of
you know there's just not enough of them
to cope with the demands that are put on
them essentially
uh now why why is this why does he say
this he says well basically you look at
small numbers and you look at sequences
of small numbers and you can be tricked
you can be tricked into seeing patterns
which then don't extrapolate to very
large numbers
or the converse of that you can be
tricked into seeing things that don't
happen which actually you know maybe
sort of you know some some
characteristic behavior can be tricked
into saying things that don't happen
which actually when you go to very large
numbers it
might be some sort of generic behavior
but looking at the small numbers it's
just not enough
and he's formulated this this this in a
in this paper here the strong law of
small numbers
it's a great little paper it's just
quite fun paper to look at and what he
does is he comes up with a bunch of
examples that sort of back up his his
claim it's done tongue-in-cheek in fact
he says this is proof by intimidation
which is i think it's a is a brilliant
line
um but anyway let's just i thought it
was worth looking at some of his
examples to see how small numbers can
trick you into
drawing erroneous conclusions so the
first example is he looks at numbers of
the form two to the two to the n
plus one
okay so if i put n equals to zero in
this
okay
then that's two to the two to the zero
is one two to the one is two plus one is
three so i would get three out
okay
if i put
n equals one into it well you can check
you get 5 out if you put n equals 2 into
it
you get 17 out if you put n equals 3
into it
you get 2 5 7
for n equals 4
you get well this number
okay so you know we're going through
there's a bunch of small numbers
smallish starting to get quite big now
and uh what do you notice about all
these well they're all prime
okay so no less than fermat
thought
that perhaps
normal numbers of this form would be
prime numbers
but of course
along came euler
probably the greatest mathematician of
all time
i'd actually went the next one up n
equals five
so we go to n equals five
so two to the two to the five plus one
turns out is equal to
641 times
six that's well some big number right
so euler was able to show that this was
true so
this pattern that seems to merge at the
small numbers is just not click you know
when you get big enough it just
disappears so it's sort of the small
numbers have tricked you there's another
so another example that they're just
just picking them out pretty randomly
another one i liked um was was this
sequence
okay again they're all related to prime
numbers number theorists love prime
numbers um number 31
clearly prime
331 is also prime
three three three one is prime
three three three three one is prime you
can see where we're going with this
right
carry on like this these these are all
prime numbers so does that mean if i
take a bunch of threes and then a one
it's a prime number well you keep on
going
and it looks like
they are until you hit eight of the
threes
if you take eight threes three three
three three
three three three three one
so this is the first one not to be prime
and this has been shown to be equal to
seventeen times one nine six oh seven
eight four three
so again small numbers tricking you into
uh
into into being something that they're
not so small numbers are almost too
interesting and
yeah all numbers are interesting
especially the small ones five billion
five hundred thousand million
prime is it's actually gets a better
result the bigger the number is